what was your favorite moment from My
Big Fat Greek Wedding we know we know
it's hard to pick just one and we're
about to get even more when My Big Fat
Greek Wedding 3 hits the big screen on
September 8th so what's the cast been up
to since filming the original and who's
returning for the third installment
we've got all the details we have Nia
vardalos to thank for the iconic film
franchise that My Big Fat Greek Wedding
has become oh and not just because she
played Doula portugolo so well when Nia
first set out to be an actor she faced
discrimination and struggled to find her
Niche she was rejected by the first
agent she got in contact with I got had
agents telling me to leave Hollywood in
part because of her Greek Heritage I was
uncastable that I was some sort of
gargoyle hanging off the side of a
building in her frustration Nia decided
to write her own part for herself that
fit her to a t the best way to do that
from her own life Nia wrote down funny
moments she experienced with her big
Greek family and she put them together
to create her one-woman show My Big Fat
Greek Wedding and yes much of the show
was based on her real life wedding it
could be what lays ahead more like I'm
probably thinking here's the thought
bubble how can I make some money off
this wedding the show took off and celeb
couple Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson saw it
and became interested in helping Nia
turn her show into a movie the rest is
history and after the first film's
success Nia went on to write produce and
star in My Big Fat Greek Wedding 2. 14
years later and according to her the
weight is entirely my fault I have
wanted to wait until motherhood well she
may have taken some time to have a baby
she still went on to write other
screenplays and appear in many TV series
she made another film based on her Greek
Heritage My Life in Ruins hello I'm
Georgia welcome to Greece I'm your tour
guide she also wrote produced and
starred in the short-lived TV series My
Big Fat Greek life based on her famous
film we're Greek and he's what we call a
non-greek she'll do the same for the
highly anticipated My Big Fat Greek
Wedding three we're going to Greece oh
yeah we all know and love John Corbett
who played Ian Miller tula's non-greek
hubby to be in My Big Fat Greek Wedding
Corbett was famously playing Aiden Shaw
in Sex in the City when the movie
premiered his characters even famously
got down on one me for two beloved
leading ladies tula and Carrie Bradshaw
I've asked quite a few women to get
married this year in the movies and TV
finally once said yes he went on to act
in shows including Parenthood sex and
drugs and rock and roll and rebel kind
of like the old
Fierce ever
these days he's appearing in reboots and
just like that where he's reuniting with
another on-screen lost love Carrie
Bradshaw this would ever happen as well
as how I met your father now it's ready
I'm Robert the meticulous Chef he's
appeared in many movies as well
including My Big Fat Greek Wedding 2 and
will be returning for My Big Fat Greek
Wedding three Michael Constantine played
Gus portugolos tula's loving and out
there father and he gave us some of the
film's best one-liners why why you want
to leave me as well as getting plenty of
laughs with his unmatched comedic timing
okay may I please date your daughter no
no Constantine was already a very
established actor who'd had a full and
successful career by the time he took on
the role of Gus he was in his 70s in My
Big Fat Greek Wedding he still returned
for My Big Fat Greek Wedding too and My
Big Fat Greek life probably because of
how much he enjoyed working on the
original movie really no joke and this
is you know not show business stuff I
love every person in this film Michael
Constantine sadly passed away in 2021 at
the age of 94. while he will certainly
be sorely missed in the third
installment the sequel will be dedicated
to his memory like her on-screen hubby
Lainey Kazan also had a long and
impressive career before joining the
cast of My Big Fat Greek Wedding Kazan
played Maria porcolos I am Maria
and welcome welcome to our home and in
addition to the many roles she took on
before she has also since made many TV
appearances in series like Gray's
Anatomy Modern Family it came back not
possible and Desperate Housewives
she too loved being a part of this
hilarious cast we became instant friends
the whole cast and we've had an
incredible 12-year relationship as
friends as a result she returned for My
Big Fat Greek life and My Big Fat Greek
Wedding too and boy was it nice to be
back my God it was like oh my god I've
come home in fact because Ian had a
little to do with the sequel happening
she'd been trying to convince her
on-screen daughter to make it happen why
did it take 14 years why did it take so
long or a movie that was a listen to me
because Anna has quite a few upcoming
projects including of course a Big Fat
Greek Wedding 3. now Andrea Martin is
another actor who delivered quite a few
of my big fret Greek weddings most
iconic moments she doesn't need me what
do you mean you don't eat no meat
that's okay I make lamb gum yes Martin
made quite a splash as aunt vula but you
may have recognized her voice from
somewhere else of course she's had a
full career appearing on Children's
shows including Sesame Street SpongeBob
SquarePants Kim Possible he's turned out
to be a fantastic big brother and Jimmy
Neutron that said you may know her voice
even if you didn't realize it was her
she sounds pretty different in many of
her roles like Miss fowl and Jimmy
Neutron today was wonderful I'm a free
spirit aside from her voice acting work
she's also been a series regular in
great news good God than difficult
people and you have to laugh as well as
appearing in many films like the
producers and How to Eat Fried Worms she
returned for My Big Fat Greek Wedding
too and My Big Fat Greek life and she
loves getting the gang back together
well I think it's a miracle doing
something like that happens I don't
think you can fake that kind of genuine
enthusiasm she's currently playing
sister Andrea in evil and is returning
for My Big Fat Greek Wedding three I
will be your favorite Joy Fatone played
Angelo but before making this foray into
acting he was best known for being a
member of NSYNC he's also acted as
producer and appeared on many TV series
such as Hannah Montana and how I met
your father frequently playing himself
well can't wait to hang back in few days
he returned for My Big Fat Greek Wedding
2 and My Big Fat Greek life it's
exciting to see you know as far as
characters kind of grow and what their
Arc is and what what happens and he will
also be returning for number three Jerry
Mendocino played Uncle tacky and he
since appeared in many movies like
Hairspray and lucky numbers 11. TV
series like Degrassi and the bridge and
voiced characters in numerous video
games as well as return for My Big Fat
Greek Wedding two he has quite a few
upcoming projects including the third
installment Gia caridis famously played
cousin Nikki Angela wait she's been in
many movies and TV series since most
notably big little lies and the Twin
Peaks reboot she returned from My Big
Fat Greek Wedding 2 and My Big Fat Greek
life she'll be in the third installment
now stravula played Athena she's
appeared in a few episodes of various TV
series but is best known for My Big Fat
Greek Wedding she returned for number
two and My Big Fat Greek life and she'll
be in number three as well they two
kinds of people Greeks and everybody
else who wish there was Greek the way we
see it there are two kinds of people
people who can't wait to see My Big Fat
Greek Wedding 3 and people who didn't
see the first two we know which kind you
are so what are you hoping to see happen
in the third movie which character are
you most looking forward to seeing again
let us know in the comments and for more
videos like this one be sure to like And
subscribe to the things
foreign
[Music]